comparamos dos recetas de pan casero la
receta de pan blanco requiere de cuatro
décimas de kilogramo de harina la receta
de pan integral requiere de 385
milésimas de kilogramo de harina cual
pan requiere menos harina el pan blanco
requiere de cuatro décimas de kilogramo
de harina y la receta del pan integral
requiere de 385 milésimas de kilogramo
de harina la forma en la que escribimos
esto es importante siempre queremos
alinear los decimales cuando comparamos
cantidades en la misma posición de valor
este es un ejemplo interesante ya que
aunque la cantidad de aquí abajo tiene
más dígitos no significa necesariamente
que sea un número más grande lo que
queremos hacer cuando comparamos números
sin importar si comparamos decimales o
no es comenzar en la posición con mayor
valor
aquí podríamos comenzar con el lugar de
las unidades pero ambas cantidades
tienen cero unidades vamos a la
siguiente posición de valor y vemos las
décimas el pan blanco requiere cuatro
décimas de harina en cambio el pan
integral requiere de tres décimas de
harina así que podríamos detenernos
justo aquí aquí tenemos más décimas de
las que hay aquí sin importar que haya
más números después de esto tenemos
centésimas y milésimas pero tienen una
posición de valor menor comparado con
las décimas su valor no es equivalente a
lo que tenemos aquí en las décimas así
que debido a que 4 es mayor que 3 y nos
encontramos en las décimas
sabemos que el pan blanco requiere de
más harina que el pan integral sin
embargo hay que tener cuidado nos
preguntan cuál de los panes requiere
menos harina por lo que la respuesta es
el pan integral 3 es menor que 4 hagamos
otro problema
un grupo de estudiantes de quinto grado
lleva un registro de las horas que han
dedicado a su proyecto de ciencias
ordena a los estudiantes de menor a
mayor según la cantidad de tiempo que
dedicaron a su proyecto de ciencias el
estudiante con menor cantidad de tiempo
debe estar arriba de la lista pausa en
el vídeo y tratan de ver si pueden
resolver esto en el ejemplo anterior
mencionamos que cuando comparamos
números es bueno alinearlos usando el
valor posicional abel tiene 5.5 andrés
tiene 5 y juanita tiene 5.17 y
nuevamente comenzamos a comparar en la
posición con mayor valor comenzamos a
las unidades y todos tienen exactamente
la misma cantidad de unidades 5 así que
ahora pasamos a la siguiente posición en
este caso es el lugar de las décimas
aquí ocurren cosas interesantes andrés
no tiene décimas aquí hay un espacio en
blanco pero lo podemos ver como 5.0 por
lo que andrés es el que tiene menos
décimas luego sigue juanita con una
décima
final está abel con cinco décimas con
eso tenemos información suficiente para
ordenarlos ya no tenemos que ver ni
siquiera el lugar de las centésimas ya
que aquí las décimas son diferentes
quien tiene el menor número de décimas
es andrés luego sigue juanita nuevamente
todos tienen la misma cantidad de
unidades pero juanita tiene menos
décimas que abel
así que al final llega a ver que tiene
la mayor cantidad de décimas no importa
que juanita también tenga siete
centésimas noten que pueden ver esto
como diecisiete centésimas que va a ser
menor que cinco décimas que también
podemos ver como 50 centésimas por lo
que la forma general de ver esto es
comenzar con el lugar de valor más
significativo el más grande y comparar
si las cantidades son iguales vamos al
siguiente lugar de valor y si las cosas
son diferentes entonces tendremos
suficiente información para comenzar a
ordenarlos